[Music]
tell me Nasir nany sends the following
message when you came you said to me as
follows I will give given sin when he
comes fine quality copper ingots
you left then but you did not do what
you promised me
you put ingots which were not good
before my messenger sits sin and said if
you want them take them if you do not
want to take them go away what do you
take me for that you treat somebody like
me with such contempt
I have sent as messengers gentlemen like
ourselves to collect the bag with my
money deposited with you but you have
treated me with contempt by sending them
back to me empty-handed several times
and that through enemy territory
is there anyone among the merchants who
trade with Talman who has treated me in
this way you alone treat my messenger
with contempt on account of that one
trifling miner of silver which I owe you
you feel free to speak in such a way
while I have given to the palace on your
behalf 1080 pounds of copper and oh my
album has likewise given 1080 pounds of
copper apart from what we both had
written on a sealed tablet to be kept in
the temple of Samus how have you treated
me for that copper you have withheld my
money back from me in enemy territory it
is now up to you to restore my money to
me in full take cognizance that from now
on I will not accept here any copper
from you that it is not of fine quality
I shall from now on select and take the
ingots individually in my own yard and I
shall exercise against you my right of
rejection because you have treated me
with contempt
[Music]